ahora les voy a presentar el concepto de
ecuaciones exactas y es otro método para
resolver un determinado tipo de
ecuaciones diferenciales este tema es
ecuaciones exactas
y antes de mostrarles lo que una
ecuación exacta es quiero hablarles un
poco de lo que es la construcción para
después poder demostrar todo lo que hay
detrás de las ecuaciones exactas y que
vean que no sale de la nada así que
vamos a pensar en una función que
depende de dos variables x y ok y vamos
a llamar a esta función si de x
si de xy así que probablemente no estás
familiarizado con la regla de la cadena
para funciones de dos variables o en
derivadas parciales pero voy a dar un
poco de intuición para ello así que si
tuviera que derivar esto respecto a x
donde además que es una función de x
esto lo podemos escribir como llegue no
no no lo lo siento no es no no es que es
sí
si de equis coma ya que es una función
de equis ok y lo podemos escribir de
esta forma ahora si tuviéramos que tomar
la derivada de pepsi con respecto a la
variable x
e insisto esto es sólo la construcción
de lo que vamos a hablar después de
ecuaciones diferenciales exactas
entonces usando la regla de la cadena y
espero que esto sea al menos
intuitivamente claro vamos a derivar si
respecto a la variable x
y luego vamos a sumar la derivada de sí
con respecto a iu y por la regla de la
cadena derivamos con respecto a x
esto debe ser un poco intuitivo estamos
tomando la derivada respecto a x y
digamos que en ese sentido podemos
cancelar la diferencial de del lado
derecho y de esta forma pues estamos
pensando que estos dos términos pues
ahora nos da la derivada total con
respecto a x ok ahora vamos a tomar una
una función particular de epsy y digo es
una es una función muy particular quizás
puede tener una una identidad bastante
complicada pero digamos por por ahora
que sí
e insisto es una función de xy de y
digamos que esta app si es una función
que depende de x digamos f 1 y después
lo multiplicamos por una función que
depende de ella ok y que además es una
suma de un montón de términos de este
estilo hasta sumar la enésima función
que depende de x por la enésima función
que depende de ella ok entonces vamos a
suponer que si tiene esta forma y así
vamos a quedar claros con la intuición
de cómo se deriva esta fórmula que
utilizamos anteriormente ahora cuál es
la derivada del sí respecto de x es una
derivada parcial ok esto sólo implica
que según lo que aprendimos en la en el
primer curso de cálculo elemental que
hay que derivar la parte derecha
respecto de x ok entonces vamos a
derivar primero la función f 1 respecto
a x
muy bien y multiplicamos por la segunda
que esto es por la regla del producto de
la derivada y ahora agregamos la
derivada de la segunda por la primera
función
ok entonces sumamos f1 de x que es la
primera por la derivada de la segunda
función ok que es simplemente la
derivada de g1
respecto de i
y ahora usamos la regla de la cadena y
derivamos por equis
ok si te parece muy extraño hay que
revisar los videos de regla de la cadena
pero esto que hice aquí
louis es sólo para una expresión de esta
suma ok
derivamos respecto a x a esto y tenemos
n términos así que vamos a seguir
agregando estas derivadas ok
hasta el último de ellos que es la
enésima función de x por la enésima
función de ayer
entonces derivamos la primera respecto
de xy multiplicamos por la segunda y
sumamos la primera de ellas por la
derivada de la segunda que escribimos
como g n prima de i y que esto
simplemente es consecuencia de la regla
del producto y multiplicamos por la
derivada de ye respecto de x debido a la
regla de la cadena
ahora tenemos estos n términos aquí del
lado derecho donde cada término era una
función de x por una función de y ok
ahora para cada uno de ellos hicimos la
regla del producto y obtuvimos toda esta
fórmula qué pasaría si agrupamos estos
términos estos términos que no tienen la
derivada de ye respecto de x ok sólo
vamos a reordenar en este paso así que
vamos a tener f1 prima de x x g1b y que
es la derivada de f1 por g1
y sumamos todos los demás términos hasta
fn prima de x
por gn v y ok eso es todo lo que suman
los primeros términos que no tienen la
derivada de ye respecto de x ahora todos
los términos que si lo tienen que es lo
que nos da vamos a ver vamos a hacerlo
con un color diferente
todos estos términos en los que vamos a
agrupar ahora vamos a hacerlo en este
paréntesis entonces tenemos f1 de x por
g1 prima de i que es derivar respecto a
a su variable
y sumamos todos los demás términos hasta
fn de x por g n prima de y ok y todo
esto lo estamos multiplicando por la
derivada de y respecto de x ahora aquí
parece algo interesante
originalmente definimos si como esta
fórmula está del lado derecho pero qué
es lo que tenemos en el término verde
bueno lo que hicimos fue tomarnos esos
términos de pepsi y derivar respecto de
x ok justo cada uno de los términos
porque tomar la derivada respecto x
simplemente es derivar f1 o más bien
todas las jefes y las funciones que son
constantes para fines de derivar
respecto de x correcto así la derivada
de esto sólo sería la derivada de f 1
ig1 porque eso es constante etcétera
entonces todos estos términos se pueden
ver como la parcial la derivada parcial
de pepsi
x ok recordemos que las gesto sólo
funcionan como constantes para eso
entonces estos términos llevarán la
misma lógica ok
aquí tomamos si íbamos a derivar lo
respecto de y por lo tanto las funciones
jefes solamente son constantes para
fines de derivar respecto de ella ok y
luego multiplicamos por la derivada de
jr respecto de x así que en otras
palabras vamos a reescribir esto esto
verde es la parcial de pge y la parcial
de epsy respecto de x más ahora esto de
morado es esta parte púrpura esto es la
parcial
vamos a cambiarle de color esto será la
parcial de pge y respecto de i
ok y luego multiplicamos por la derivada
de y respecto de x
eso es básicamente lo que quería
mostrarles en este vídeo porque ahora si
ya me estoy quedando sin tiempo ahora lo
que usamos fue la regla de la cadena
para varias variables cuando la segunda
variable es una función que depende de
la primera ok que también es una función
de x sips y es una función de x ideye
utilizando las derivadas parciales
podemos encontrar esta expresión ok la
expresión de la parcial de pepsi
respecto de x si ya no era una función
de x o si era independiente pues
entonces simplemente la derivada de jr
respecto de x se hace 0 ok y entonces
pues la parcial de eps y nos queda como
la parcial de pepsi que realmente es
haber hecho nada ok
de todos modos quiero que tengan esta
fórmula en mente
para poder utilizar la intuición que
generamos en este vídeo vamos a utilizar
esta propiedad en la próxima serie de
vídeos y vamos a poder comprender
exactamente qué son las ecuaciones
exactas ok en este vídeo solo hemos dado
intuición no hemos dicho que es una
ecuación exacta pero para eso habrá
tiempo